hello everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I get to talk to two
filmmakers behind an exceptional
midnighter here at Sundance in my
mother's skin my God your movie it
buried its way into my brain and it's
not leaving cicada Style
cicadas creeped me out in general
cicadas are awesome creatures like they
really just feed and feed and I'm glad
to be the queen of cicadas and the
process too of the rebirth exactly that
that's what's the purpose of like having
cicada for your character correct
because initially it was a different
insect right there
but my production designer Ben padera
told me and his partner Carlos told me
like maybe we can play around with the
cicada element because of the rebirth
and how our protagonistala are rebirth
and then
perfect pairing there Kenneth I'm going
to give this duty to you because our
audience might not know what your movie
is just yet can you give a brief
synopsis of in my mother's skin so it's
a so the film happens
in the last months of World War II and
you follow this young innocent
protagonist named tala and together with
her younger brother and her very sick
mother they wait for their father to
arrive in this isolated mansion and then
one day when the mother gets very sick
tala is forced to accept help coming
from a flesh eating fairy played by
Jasmine stop giving me that look
that promised her protection
so
I'm gonna get to this later but you just
name dropped tala she's so
oh my gosh how how does a young actor
carry a movie like this she's so amazing
I mean until now I'm still all like
working with her I mean working with you
guys oh my gosh no even as a co-actor
like when I whenever I shared the set
and the scene with her she's she
commands attention and and as the fairy
you know I'm meant to be the one like
commanding the scene and I feel like the
way she reacts is just so she absorbs
everything and she's 15 is that right
she's 15 but she just turned she just
turned 16.
um but she does have a lot of theater
background so that's that really she's
amazing whatever experiences she had
whoever trained her I mean a plus worked
there because she is something else in
this I wanted to go back to the
beginning kind of for you because it is
a feat to get a first feature off the
ground and I feel like many think like
after you do it once you could do it
again was that the case with this
feature now was it any more difficult or
was it easier now that you had another
film under your belt
it's a bit weird because I wrote this
script oh no this concept Way Way Back
in 2015 as a short film
and it was based off a French film and
pants Labyrinth by Guillermo deltaro I
think it's obvious I like any reference
to Guillermo and and you could feel it
and I like that feeling so may this
short film and eventually add a
privilege to made my first official film
it's called ma then after that 2018 I
discovered the
the concept again and approach my
producers from epic media bread and
Bianca
to maybe we can play around with this
story that I really want to tell
and then the process is like a bit long
for uh I think for a Filipino project
it's a bit long because we started
writing 2018.
so it's like four years
of writing and developing and research
so yeah I mean it's really amazing fun
process talking with everyone giving
ideas about the story
and we're very happy to have this kind
of story now so you should be you should
be very proud so many many years of work
went into writing the script what would
you say is the biggest difference
between how you initially pictured this
movie panning out and then the movie you
wound up with in the end I mean
everything's compromised
but I'm very happy how it came out
uh
in the short film it's a
when I first wrote this story
it was periodless film like I don't know
what setting or the milieu of this film
and then cut to 2020 when the pandemic
hits
I was talking with my father and and he
was telling me
the story of my grand grandfather who
was a guerrilla Soldier Way Way Back in
World War II and he was telling me this
the anxiety you know the the
claustrophobia that the depression of
war and having that external enemy
coming in your house you know
and it's World War II and I felt the
same way when pandemic happened
so I told my producers I think we need
to make this a world way too
so yeah I think that's the biggest
difference between the short and this
one that's a very very effective element
that you added to this
um Jasmine so you get this script I've
got to imagine there are some big
burning questions about you know like
what your character is capable of what
she's all about so when you first get
the script what are some of the biggest
questions you had for Kenneth in order
to fully be able to like access what's
going through her mind initially I
really just wanted to understand first
how she would visually appear like what
did she look like what because that in
itself is a big factor when you're
watching horror films right what what
this flesh-eating Fairy like she's not a
fairy you know she's flesh eating she
she invades the the body of the person
that she attacks and so I felt like
having that first hand
um picture or visual imagination helped
me go back to the script and reread it
again and just the fact that there was
this this play on her being looking like
a religion religious artifact or Saint
or statue or mother Mary and our we
actually the costume in itself looks
like our baby Jesus Santo Nino in the
Philippines because he has that the the
frame around his face he has all the
embellishments on the big garments that
they wear and it looks exactly like what
the fairy looks like and so I felt that
that was such a freaky way of
incorporating religion hope and at the
same time
um just horror like how can you that
makes us religion and horror I think is
a big thing especially in our country so
because we're mainly Roman Catholic so
that that was what got me to jump on and
start asking questions and like how
serious do you want the character to be
do you want her to be freaky and like
scary right away but Kenneth told me
that he really wanted her to have this
kind of solemn
feel that every time she would come on
screen it wasn't like a jump scare or
like you you didn't have
that traditional fear
it was kind of like a simmering fear
every time she would pop up so that was
what I enjoyed yeah and great success in
that respect that is what you feel thank
you I have so many follow-up questions I
guess bringing up that feel I don't know
if I'm you know getting too specific
about it but how much are you thinking
about like every little Nuance of your
facial expression in every scene as the
movie progresses because like it it is a
like a Salomon very simple performance
but any little like twitch or different
look or if your eyebrows move a certain
way can completely change the tone of a
moment oh yeah definitely and I would
often ask him if he would be bothered by
certain like movements that I would make
with my face because sometimes I would
be conscious about my forehead and I
really wanted her to come off as this
like statuesque you know kind of
porcelain facade so that that would
initiate the freakishness of the fairy
character but he said no it's it's okay
that's fine but because it also adds
character and depth to the fairy without
you having to show too much emotion and
and we also played around with the voice
like we experimented how we wanted that
and then in post we we did a few
recordings of how to how to add just
another layer but still using the
original voice that we used on set in
the original but you're the one who gave
me the idea of a fairy not blinking at
all that's right that's right how do you
do that well the biggest inspiration was
the scene in the lighthouse with William
Defoe I mean he was saying I think a
three minute line and his eyes were
peeled open and I want that freaked me
out like when I was watching that scene
for the first time
I wasn't sure if I I wasn't blinking
like was why blinking the same time he
was blinking so I had to re-watch the
scene again and like and that freaked me
out watching it and his presence and
energy just in that scene so I think
that I wanted that I wanted to bring
that to them it really worked
effective also it's like once someone
once someone tells me like don't blink
anymore then all of a sudden I'm like
blinking and I can't stop exactly
something else I am always really
interested to know about lore and like
movie Bibles and everything so Kenneth
how much did you think all of that
through with the fairy in terms of like
where she came from why she's there in
particular like if she even has an end
goal or if it's just this like constant
cycle that could never be broken how
much of that kind of information do you
have all the elements of
the law of the films basically based on
the existing mythology in the
Philippines which is the Aswang which
which is the monster and the Encanto
which is the ferry
and growing up as a kid in the province
I mean even even in the Philippines you
keep hearing these stories about the
Aswang and the encantos
and in Canada's living inside this tree
and giving no powers or even giving
fruits to this to the people
and growing up listening to that it
really stopped me even like for sure for
you right oh yeah yeah because these are
things you would hear like from your
aunties uncles your parents yeah and
they try to scare you with it like don't
go out late at night yeah because the
Encanto will you know but in this film I
really want to give something new
towards the Lord towards that mythology
that's why we
I really abandoned something some things
to just to make it something new
and I'm really happy that it came out
this week something new and
Unforgettable I really like there's
certain visuals in this that I will not
Shake one thing that randomly crossed my
mind I don't know if you've considered
it but how do you think the story might
have changed if it was bayani and not
tala who encountered the fairy
oh that's a good question huh
because
because in my head it's really like a
young girl living in this adult life
living with you know a lot of
um grown-ups and trying to live
and you know lost his her innocence in a
way but with biryani's character I
really want him to be this because tala
I want Carla's character to show the
very
tail side of this very crazy scary world
which is the world war and for bayani I
really want him to to see the real
horror of the war
that's the that's why I really want them
to you know contrast and beat each other
and I'm happy with these kid actors that
really pull this off
my heart is crumbling as I'm revisiting
everything while you answer that
question bringing bringing up the kids
here again even with all of your
experience is there anything you saw
that two of them do on this set that you
wish you could go back in time and tell
yourself when you were first starting
out like try give that a shot you could
be that bold oh yeah definitely like
these kids are just fantastic and they
take directions so well they're very
patient and I think
you know and these times as well where
patience is kind of running out because
how fast where our social media clocks
you know running but they're able to
really live in the moment and take
direction from our acting coaches as
well on set and even just from co-actors
so I think that's what I would tell
myself if I was going back 14 years ago
I'd be like hey girl just listen trust
like yes you know things but trust
because there's a bigger picture here
and so I've done that I wrote bayani's
character really differently
from what you saw in the film because
Ira I wrote the bayani scatter as
describe baby the man you know scaredy
cat kind of boy but when I saw James
maybe Australia for the first time and
he decided
he gave different Persona to the
character and I really want that Persona
so I changed everything for that Persona
and it really worked I am very happy I
revised the script for her oh it did
work it works so their Dynamic together
couldn't be better
I always I always don't like asking
someone like what is next after you're
just basically releasing your miracle
that is making any movie but I've seen a
lot of pieces out there that say you
want a Hard director to keep an eye out
for a look at you look at Kenneth and
horror is my favorite genre I love all
storytelling horror is my number one and
now I would like to keep you in this
genre so is there any particular like
theme or corner of the horror genre that
you've yet to tap into that you'd be
eager to explore in the future so I'm
developing a project right now
and it's all about
generational Gap I really want to touch
on that topic
and it's all about old people
and I want to you know make it uh
Something Magic
realism in a way
and there's a touch of heart but it's
all about this generational gap between
new generations and the old ones and I
really want to tap on that I feel like I
already feel your ability to tap into
those but then that idea feels like it's
going to take it to a Next Level and I'm
into it I can't wait to see more from
you more from you but I also can't wait
to be able to shout to everybody about
every little ounce of in my mother's
skin because you have accomplished
something special here congratulations
thank you thank you very much to
everybody out there in my mother's skin
do not miss it and stay tuned we'll have
more from Sundance for you real soon